[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 llevamos más de un año de pandemia de
coronavirus y las restricciones para
evitar los contagios el confinamiento el
distanciamiento social el cierre de
lugares de ocio o el teletrabajo han
transformado completamente nuestras
vidas uno de los efectos ha sido el
aumento de los casos de depresión para
hablarnos de este tema hoy hace escala
en parís el psicoanalista y psiquiatra
francés de origen argentino el doctor
juan david nacio muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros no muy contentos yo
también de estar en escala en parís y
poder contar lo que me está pasando como
doctor no como lo que está pasando como
doctor haciendo desde bueno juanadina si
usted es natural de rosario en argentina
pero trabaja en francia desde hace
muchos años desde 1969 ese año llegó
para estudiar junto al célebre
psicoanalista
jacques lacan ha dado clases en la
universidad y es el fundador de los
seminarios psicoanalíticos de parís ha
publicado 34 libros traducidos a 14
idiomas y el último de ellos es este tul
monte tilton ver con depresión todo el
mundo puede caer en depresión por la
editorial les llega para yo y justamente
en lo que les está pasando últimamente
con sus pacientes es que ha visto que
con la pandemia ha surgido una especie
de nueva depresión una depresión que
usted ha llamado depresión
kobe 19 qué características tiene esta
iglesia le cuento y cuento a los
telespectadores pasa lo siguiente desde
el mes de marzo y me he dado cuenta que
recibía pacientes cada vez más numerosos
no solamente yo sino otros colegas
psiquiatras y esos pacientes muy
angustiados muy angustiados por la
situación y algunos deprimidos
tanto es que poco a poco me di cuenta
que hay una en un tipo de depresión que
yo llamo depresión epidémica porque está
muy ligada a la crisis sanitaria que
estamos viviendo hoy día entonces esa
depresión me pareció una depresión como
inédita una particular modo de
deprimirse que no es lo mismo depresión
que he conocido
tantos años antes con mis pacientes
habitualmente y que ha motivado ese
libro que acaba de salir todo el mundo
puede caer en depresión todo el mundo
puede deprimirse ese libro fue hecho
antes de la depresión con 19
respondo rápidamente a la pregunta del
libro porque muchos telespectadores
decidí ahora cuál es la respuesta a todo
el mundo puede deprimirse la respuesta
es no
todo el mundo no puede deprimirse quiere
decir que hay gente que se va a deprimir
porque hay una pre depresión porque hay
un terreno favorable a la depresión y
hay otra gente que no bueno pero dicho
esto vayamos a lo que usted subraya
signos de la depresión cavill 10
efectivamente se confirma que hay una
depresión típica kobe 19 que está muy
ligada a la crisis sanitaria a tal punto
que yo diría que esta depresión comí 19
existe hoy mientras exista la crisis
sanitaria la epidemia y las medidas de
restricción y se va a parar cuando se
pare la crisis sanitaria y cómo se ha
utilizado mucha tristeza por el encierro
o incertidumbre por el futuro no saber
qué hacer o por no ver a los seres
queridos como se magnifican está ahí
como se caracteriza como no antes de
caracterizar la es bueno recordar lo que
es una depresión normal porque la
palabra depresión se usa mucho y mucha
gente no sabe lo que es la depresión
la depresión se caracteriza por tres
cosas la depresión clásica primero una
tristeza profunda que no se sabe de
dónde viene y que dura segundo la
persona se trata mal el deprimido
clásico no se quiere ha perdido el
estima de sí mismo y tercero el
deprimido clásico es una persona que
está sin energía sin ganas está cansada
duerme y a pesar de dormir se despierta
cansado esas son las tres
características y muchas más pero
vayamos rápido a lo que es el yo diría
el retrato de la persona deprimida
clásica el deprimido
kobe 19 es diferente la tristeza es una
tristeza ansiosa es una persona que
además de estar triste está angustiada y
está angustiada y además tiene la
particularidad de que en lugar de no
quererse a sí misma como en la depresión
clásica
enojada con los otros sobre todo enojada
con los responsables con las autoridades
con todos aquellos que toman una palabra
de autoridad como pueden ser los bienes
con que pasan en los platós de
televisión o inclusive el gobierno por
supuesto es un deprimido que está mal
con el mundo y abc si está mal con todos
está irritable es un deprimido ir
ansioso e irritable y además es una
persona que tiene la particularidad de
tenerse como angustia y esa angustia va
subiendo es una el deprimido kobe 19 no
es un deprimido ya es un deprimido luego
de que ayuna como una sucesión de crisis
de angustia la angustia asia acumulada
en crescendo eso van creyendo perfecto
ayuda exactamente hay un creyendo de
angustia
entonces dura un tiempo no es un hombre
o una mujer que se deprime hoy el
deprimido clásico se deprime hoy el
deprimido condiciones de seva
deprimiendo o mejor dicho seva
angustiando hasta llegar a un punto
máximo en el que se deprime pero yo
quisiera hacer bien el esquema porque lo
estudie mucho y me gustaría transmitirlo
a los telespectadores fíjese primero
empieza con que la crisis sanitaria y
las medidas de restricción han impuesto
privaciones frustraciones que todos
vivimos la mayor parte de nosotros
soportamos más a la vida no nos
adaptamos nos enojamos por tal o cual
cosa pero nos adaptamos el futuro
deprimido kobe 19 no se adapta bien vive
está inquieto está muy inquieto está
está con miedo de enfermarse y con miedo
de enfermar
no soporta el confinamiento entonces las
angustias aumenta es un hombre más
angustiado que lo normal y se va
aumentando la angustia hasta que llega
un punto de exasperación es muy
importante se puede comparar con alguna
otra depresión que se detectara por otro
acontecimiento es decir o estamos ante
algo muy nuevo estamos ante algo muy
nuevo en todo caso en la larga
experiencia que yo tengo como psiquiatra
y como psicoanalista para mí esto nunca
lo he visto hasta ahora de ver que una
persona y lo he visto con mis pacientes
lo he visto con pacientes que me llaman
a veces en el momento de que va subiendo
me llaman porque está muy angustiado a
veces es la mujer la que me llama por me
dice mire doctor mi marido está inviable
no le he pedido por favor que no vea más
la televisión y cierro la televisión
porque ve la televisión y se pone loco y
es una depresión que termina con cuando
termine la pandemia o habrá secuelas se
termina cuando se termina
a lo que estoy contando es que antes de
que la depresión llegue a ida primero
hay angustia una angustia anormal y esa
angustia normal se va montando hasta que
la persona llega a un punto de
exasperación esto es muy importante esta
palabra exasperación es decir que está
con una crisis de enojo grande pero no
solo contra el gobierno de pronto está
exasperado contra todo
la mujer le trae algo y está enojado es
decir está enojado con los chicos está
enojado con todo entonces primero
hay cuatro eslabones primer eslabón la
crisis sanitaria con las prohibiciones
injusticias segundo eslabón la angustia
que sube en creyendo como usted dijo
aída sube la angustia tercero la
exasperación y el cuarto y la bonne más
importante es la can el cansancio la
persona se cansa
enojarse ya no se enoja más está está
como desarrolle decimos en francés
desencantado de nada está agotado
ella pre y después viene el último
eslabón que es la depresión como yo le
dije recién es una depresión que también
afecta a niños no estamos hablando de
una generación perdida acá sí porque hay
niños que sólo conocen estos los más
pequeñitos digamos que no digamos que la
depresión primero que nada por suerte la
depresión en los niños es rara lo que sí
es muy frecuente es la depresión en los
bebés recién nacidos y en los
adolescentes y en los adolescentes la
depresión toma formas diferentes por
ejemplo la violencia es una manera de
estar deprimido la droga es una manera
nosotros los llamamos eso depresión
enmascarada porque no está triste el
adolescente no está triste como nuestro
deprimido kobe 19
esta es como si el enojo del comit 19 se
tradujera en acciones violentas
es decir el adolescente que está
deprimido no siente la depresión no
siente la tristeza pero está va y hace
actos de contra
por ejemplo actos de lo que está pasando
ahora con las bandas y que matan o que
hay muchas violencia no le a nadie
exactamente la violencia es una forma
enmascarada de depresión no querría
terminar porque nos queda muy poco
tiempo sin que nos dé unas claves para
evitar caer en esa espiral que nos ha
contado y en ese
en esta exasperación que nos lleva al
cansancio ya la depresión muy gracias de
esa pregunta aída palau porque es muy
importante que lo que digo acá pueda
también servir si usted tiene un amigo
que está deprimido y sobre todo un amigo
está deprimido por lo que está pasando
primero que nada sepa que para ir
ayudarlo a él usted tiene que estar bien
primera medida primer consejo que esté
bien no podemos ayudar a alguien y si
nosotros estar angustiado primero estar
bien segundo acercarse a él hablar con
él dejarlo hablar no hable usted no no
venga a consolarlo déjelo hablar no le
diga este mira ya va a pasar pero no te
preocupe no déjelo venir a usted y que y
escúchelo a veces aída
en un silencio pero un silencio
auténtico un silencio emotivo un
silencio de cercanía es mucho mejor que
todas las palabras de consolación que
podemos decir es muy importante esto y
lo más importante que quisiera decirles
es que cuando está alguien mal tiene que
usted tener confianza estar usted
convencido de que este problema se va a
parar y es verdad esta depresión kobe 19
se va a terminar cuando se termine la
epidemia bueno pues con esa frase de
esperanza nos quedamos muchísimas
gracias doctor nacio por haber estado
con nosotros y habernos despejado tantas
dudas muy bien gracias y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir por internet en rf y mundo.com
bien france24 puntocom hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]